Hey, I'm Emily.
>> And I'm Ajay.
>> And we'll be your instructors.
We're here to help you learn about
using location within a website.
Let's get started with some questions.
Are you looking to build a dating site
for all the left handed vegetarians that
live within a one hour bike
ride of your parents house?
Or, perhaps create an online
vacation planning experience for
users in Thailand.
Or do you just want to add a
location-related feature into your site
that's instantly familiar to your users?
If you answered yes to
any of those questions,
you've come to the right course.
Google Maps is used by over 2
million developers worldwide.
>> Using location adds another
dimension to a website and
unlocks a huge palette of features.
Using Google's Maps and
Location Services, means users get a
familiar experience with reliable data.
>> In this course you'll learn how to
use different Google Maps APIs to build
your very own location enabled site.
You'll be able to use the tools
Google has available to display
a personalize map, and provide users
with fun and useful information.
>> This course is relevant to anyone
who has any level of experience in
web development,
is planning to build a website.
Or just dreams of learning about
using location capabilities
to build awesome stuff.
Throughout this course, you'll see
us build a realistic listing app,
with a variety of features that you'll
be able to use when you want to start
building your maps API
based application.
>> Let's get started by creating
a developer project, and
enabling the APIs so you can build
your site through out the course.